and as we await news on the vaccine
coronavirus cases
unfortunately continue to soar yesterday
was the second highest daily total
since the pandemic began our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
santa monica california for us this
morning david good morning to you
what's the situation there in l.a county
well look consider this analogy if the
vaccine is the fire hose
and the fire department is coming the
forest is burning
and the virus is the forest burning the
virus is raging now
more than ever consider here in l.a
county this is the most populated county
in the nation
covet hospitalizations over the course
of the last month
have quadrupled
the post thanksgiving surge of
coronavirus coronaviruses here it is on
us
and it is pushing cases to unimaginable
highs
in los angeles county the overwhelming
loss of life
brought public health director barbara
ferrer to tears the more terrible truth
is that over 8 000 people sorry
over 8 000 people who were beloved
members of their families
are not coming back nationwide covet
hospitalizations are at their highest
levels ever up nearly 80 percent
in just the last month this is
providence st mary in apple valley
california
there's a tent set up outside to triage
those coveted patients arriving
and the lobby is now an inpatient
coveted unit because they run out of
room
i know today that we have 60 patients
holding in our emergency department
that are waiting for beds inside the
hospital some of them have been there as
long as seven days
consider the health care workers who've
been going non-stop for months
and are getting sick at the university
of kansas health system there are more
than 150 staff members who are out
after testing positive for the virus and
they've got another 121 who are out
because they're awaiting test results at
this minneapolis hospital covet patients
are now being treated in rooms that are
usually reserved for pediatric patients
it's very hard and it's a reality right
now like we are holding people's hands
on their last breasts
every day and then there's the work of
father michael lewis
a roman catholic priest in el paso texas
which has been overwhelmed recently with
coronavirus hospitalizations
he is so busy giving last rites to covet
patients who are dying almost on a daily
basis that his bishop recently told him
it is your full-time job how many of
your calls to give last rites involve
covet patients
uh right now almost all of them i
realize that i'm the last person that's
going to see this person alive
that they're alone in that room
and as much as i would like to stay
there and be with them
as they breathe their last
i can't because there are other patients
to see
you know father mike told us many times
patients families will say to him can i
have a picture i want to see that you
gave them the last rights
and i said well is it because they don't
believe you and he said no not not
necessarily
sometimes it's because those left to do
the living
simply want the tangible proof to look
at as a peace of mind
that their loved one was given the last
rights in their final moment
anthony yeah just some comfort david
that's all thank you very much